[Música]
[Aplausos]
si os pregunto cuántos pantalones tenéis
cuántas camisetas o vestidos quizás me
podéis decir un número cinco diez quince
pero si os pregunto de qué material
están hechas las prendas dónde se han
fabricado cien empresas han intervenido
en esa cadena de suministro pues quizá
vuestra respuesta es pues no no me he
fijado las he comprado por el precio
porque me quedaban bien me gustaban
que levante la mano quien ha venido
desnudo hoy aquí
así es nadie todos nos vestimos todos
los días a todos tenemos que salir
vestidos somos parte de la industria de
la moda nos guste más nos guste menos y
de hecho aunque no queramos la moda
expresa en cierto modo quiénes somos
nuestra forma de pensar y también pues a
veces se nos juzga por ello lo que los
demás piensan de nosotros también se
refleja en cierto modo por lo que
llevamos puesto a mí me gusta la moda he
comprado mucho a lo largo de mi vida
nunca de forma compulsiva lo tengo que
reconocer pero sí que es verdad que he
llegado a acumular mucha cantidad y es
curioso que sobre algo que utilizamos
todos los días en realidad sepamos
tampoco se trate como un secreto las
personas que están involucradas en esa
cadena de suministro de la industria
textil
en todas esas empresas en el fondo no
sabemos muy bien el impacto que la moda
tiene en el planeta por lo tanto hay que
romper con este tabú mi forma de hacerlo
ha sido pues a través de la
investigación en derecho en concreto en
el fashion o el derecho de la moda que
es una disciplina que persigue pues
resolver problemas jurídicos
relacionados con la industria textil
también de la belleza de la cosmética y
a lo largo de estos años estudiando
sobre el derecho de la moda pues me ha
dado cuenta en contacto con expertos con
alumnos que verdaderamente queremos un
cambio un cambio en la forma de
fabricar
consumir y distribuir esa moda pero por
qué por qué necesitamos este cambio cuál
es el impacto que la moda tiene en el
planeta
pues veréis si yo decidiera pues hacer
una compra de un pantalón vaquero ahora
cuando salga aquí en la tienda de
ecommerce donde normalmente compro pues
el vaquero me va a costar unos veinte
euros
pero también voy a añadir una camiseta
al carrito a la cesta de 6 commerce 5
euros en total pues me voy a gastar
25 euros creéis que ese es el coste real
de esa compra que estoy haciendo
tenéis que tener en cuenta que la
industria de la moda es una de las más
contaminantes algunos expertos han
señalado que es la segunda la tercera en
realidad no me importa no nos importa
cuál sea su posición lo que sí es cierto
es que es una la industria textil es una
industria donde hay numerosas empresas
para llegar a meter en el carrito del
e-commerce esas prendas pues hemos
tenido muchas personas trabajando allá
las que se han encargado de cultivar el
algodón porque es la materia prima que
yo elegido para mis prendas pero también
todo el hilado el tenido la confección
propiamente dicha de la prenda
posteriormente yo justo no tiene que ser
en los mismos países
posteriormente todo lo que tiene que ver
con él
y poner botones el etiquetado o el
planchado hasta que finalmente llega al
consumidor a nuestras tiendas que
normalmente donde se fabrica pues está
verdaderamente lejos pero qué podemos
hacer nosotros si verdaderamente este no
es el coste real pues bien en realidad
para saber el coste real de esas dos
prendas que estoy comprando deberíamos
añadir otros ocho elementos más a
nuestro carrito en primer lugar el coste
hídrico de cultivar el algodón de lo que
están fabricados las prendas diez mil
litros de agua son necesarios para
fabricar un simple pantalón vaquero y
2500 litros de agua para una camiseta de
algodón me preguntaréis por qué tanto sí
porque el algodón hay que cultivarlo hay
que regarlo hay que echarle muchos
pesticidas para que salga adelante por
lo tanto el coste hídrico el impacto
sobre el planeta pues como podéis
comprobar
brutal pero es que además yo he elegido
una camiseta de color rojo un pantalón
azul y eso hay que tenerlo no sale solo
y de esos venidos de las prendas pues se
vierten muchos residuos a mares océanos
de acuerdo pero no queda ahí la cosa
también sin darme cuenta he elegido un
pantalón con un efecto desgastado por lo
tanto hay que añadir también a nuestro
carrito la técnica del sandblasting es
decir se añade arena prisión hay
personas que añaden arena presión a
nuestros vaqueros para que tengan ese
toque no más moderno más desgastado pero
es que el problema que deberíamos añadir
el coste para la salud de esas personas
que realizan esta técnica unos cuantos
años realizando el sandblasting pues
provoca pues serios problemas de salud
problemas respiratorios muy severos que
impiden a esas personas pues luego
llevar una vida normal y la verdad que
eso contando con que sean adultos porque
en la industria textil trabajan todavía
muchos niños niños menores de 10 años
unicef señala que en el mundo ojos no
sólo la industria textil hay alrededor
160 millones de niños trabajando en
condiciones pues esclavas
además también sin darme a lo mejor
demasiada cuenta pues he añadido al
carrito una camiseta fabricada en la
india una gran producción una de las
mayores empresas o la gran cantidad en
la india hay una gran cantidad de
empresas de hilado y es una práctica muy
habitual ahí es el psuv manga liu es
decir se va por los barrios más pobres
de la india se coge a se recluta a niñas
entre 12 y 13 años y se las hace
trabajar en condiciones la verdad que
muy duras pero sobre todo es que no
cobran un salario cada mes cada semana
por esas largas jornadas sino que la
empresa se lo da algún día justo antes
de casarse y diréis porque bueno pues
porque en la india es necesario para
poder contraer matrimonio una mujer
necesita pagar la dote a la familia del
marido y si no lo hace pues no se casa y
si en la india no te casas pues
socialmente estás
fuera por lo tanto el psuv mangal y pues
también tendríamos que añadir lo también
el co2 como os decía normalmente las
prendas se fabrican muy lejos de donde
las compramos uno con dos millones de
toneladas de co2 se vierten cada año de
acuerdo pero y diréis bueno y cuando me
canso de las prendas porque verdad que
me va a costar 25 euros no es mucho que
hago con ellas pues normalmente van
directamente a la basura o se queman o
al mar o al océano es decir en españa
por ejemplo sólo una de cada diez
prendas se reciclan
qué podemos hacer en relación a esto
vosotros podéis hacer algo claro que si
yo os planteó tres escenarios en primer
lugar revisa tu armario porque es
probable que cuando te decides a comprar
yo que quería comprar ese pantalón esa
camiseta pues es probable que ya lo
tenga que no pueda construir consum izar
cambiarlo darle un toque distinto pero
en el fondo ya lo tengo si tengo para
que comprar pero es cierto que para
llegar a ese nivel de concienciación a
ese nivel de me lo planteo pues se
necesita cierta educación y por eso
estoy creando un proyecto
educación y el fin es que en el mundo
universitario en el que me encuentro
pues en definitiva poner sobre la mesa
temas que algunos son tabús otros no
pero que tienen un verdadero impacto y
sobre todo yo quiero con mis estudiantes
tomar acción dejar huella aquí vale y en
definitiva en este primer escenario
primero antes de comprar
y le doy una vuelta pero claro y esto
nos lleva al segundo escenario
compro conscientemente porque en algún
momento pues voy a tener comprar pero
aunque compre en este segundo escenario
investigó sobre las prendas es decir yo
tengo que comprar a diario o no a diario
no estoy exagerando pero sí que es
verdad que soy madre tengo dos niños de
cuatro y cinco años y la ropa pues se
les queda pequeña que hago cuando compro
bueno pues investigo es decir miro las
etiquetas consulto en redes sociales en
internet donde cuál es la cadena de
suministro de esa empresa donde quiero
comprar me informó la etiqueta que a
veces yo antes cogía directamente y la
cortaba porque me molestan pero desde
hace unos años pues me fijo mucho las
etiquetas en el fondo para tener
verdaderamente información a la hora de
comprar y poder valorar las etiquetas no
deberían ser así deberían ser más así
pero no os asustéis no va a cambiar la
normativa en cuanto a etiquetas en
relación a esto es decir es para que
veáis que en el fondo debería haber
mucha más información más transparencia
y las empresas lo tienen fácil hoy en
día con el block change la cadena de
bloques con un simple código qr podrían
aportar mucha mayor transparencia y eso
haría que la moda que llevamos pues
fuera mucho más tuviera mucho más valor
dijera de nosotros mucho más y esto nos
lleva en el fondo al tercer escenario
exige no te conformes comprar vamos a
tener que acabar comprando pero de qué
modo si yo ahora o vosotros a lo mejor
esta tarde lo vais a hacer tuviera que
comprar no voy a añadir al carrito mano
de obra esclava ni de mujeres ni de
niños ni de cualquier persona de acuerdo
porque porque voy a exigir y en la
empresa a la que voy a comprarle a la
marca la que voy a comprar las prendas
quiero que tenga fuertes programas de
cumplimiento normativo es decir que me
diga claramente que sea transparente si
está vigilando a los proveedores de su
cadena de suministro
lo necesito antes de comprar yo como
consumidora no sé vosotros yo no
necesito que una marca que me gusta me
esté ofreciendo una colección cada dos
semanas no no necesito yo lo que
necesito es que no se maltraten a los
niños que se respeten los derechos de
las mujeres de los hombres involucrados
en esa cadena de suministro y ojo
tampoco voy a añadir esos 10.000 litros
de agua por el pantalón y los 2500 por
la camiseta porque no voy a añadir eso
bueno porque puedo acudir a un algodón
ecológico hoy en día ya es posible tengo
que investigar tengo que informarme el
algodón ecológico no implica gasto
hídrico claro que sí pero menor menos
pesticidas
y también además existen otras materias
primas como el lío 6 que se extrae de la
celulosa es una fibra natural que se
extrae de la celulosa o incluso ya hay
empresas que tienen una investigación
muy desarrollada y extraen por ejemplo
la piña de los residuos de la
agricultura de los posos del café fibras
naturales para hacer prendas por lo
tanto es posible la tecnología y la
economía circular hacen que este cambio
de paradigma pues no sea un mañana pueda
ser uno hoy pero para eso tenemos que
bueno apostar por un consumo responsable
basado en valores y en el fondo que la
ropa no sólo diga de nosotros en sentido
estético sino también ético yo ya tengo
mis escenarios hablemos más del tema te
reto a que hago reto que vosotros
encontréis vuestros escenarios revisa tu
armario
investiga sobre tus prendas y antes de
comprar exige muchas gracias
[Aplausos]